at one out at Julie Walters I don't
think he ever mentioned educating Rita
you didn't get the Oscar but you did get
a bastard Anu yeah did you were very
excited to win the BAFTA stop it gonna
go on about I had had a drop taken back
that's all and I didn't expect to win
and in those days the BAFTA Award this
is a very long time before you people we
used to have a dinner before can that
how much of a mistake is that that's a
disaster it is apps that's a big ol
known especially in England oh yeah I
mean people want absolutely plastic well
not everybody
the first one I've been to when they
were put they just filled your gas odds
terribly nervous anyway in case I might
have to go up you know so it's a you
know in all of this it was that deadly
when I went I thought I was being really
funny and help this awesome really piss
I don't know gee because we have a
picture of that night
you you really can't tell I don't think
you can tell
take it away take it away take event I
ended up under the table with a very
famous action I can't remember who it
was we were putting the early actors can
we were putting the whole world to write
well I don't know why she won I won Miss
meeting Princess Anne she's never spoken
to missing good
Kate wins it when you talk about your
Oscar I really like it cuz you're just
so no faults want to see you wanted to
win it you loved winning it it was just
a brilliant thing well even now and it
was about seven years ago oh no was it's
it's the most extraordinary moment I
mean I had you be nominated a bunch of
time what do you see the thing is you
get really good at losing weight dick
Ellis nominated more than a couple of
times and what you nominated twice that
same year no I had been I had a category
don't let me say it said it for you so
you knew you were up in two galleries
that year I was what had happened was I
had two films come out at the same time
which not not uncommon actually and but
it just so happened that both of those
films were getting this type of
attention and I went to the Golden
Globes that year and I had been
nominated in two different categories
and won them both oh it was quite
fabulous action sorry everybody else but
greedy I have a showing
completely showing off 100 words right
and then and then when I did when I did
win it was a it was a really fantastic
moment I've got to say it was you know
there's personal fist-pumping moment the
biggest one of my whole life but you're
really generous with the Oscar on you
well one dries you know everyone the
thing is first of all it's very heavy I
just need to say that it weighs about
six or seven pounds it's really
surprisingly heavy so and everyone wants
to have a hold of course and wants to
stand up and go I'd like to thank my
primary school teachers and my mum and
dad and so the best place really for
Oscar is actually the loo because then
when everyone goes in for a wee rapoo
they can really take their time in front
of the mirror with Oscar you tell
because they flash and there's another
five minutes you're playing with us
come on how is Oscar they got oh my god
but yeah it's a lot it's a lot of what
your contest is too long for P too short
for Pooh you know they're in there we
are because you went through the whole
Oscar thing Michael did you go with a
speech in your pocket or and no I didn't
uh I don't know why I never really
prepare speeches I probably should
looking back some of the ones that I've
made especially a best man speech that I
did one time which was awful
I'm just reading kind of went blank yeah
it was it's okay they're divorced now
you didn't waste your time you're not
joking are you but yeah no I never
prepared
well he used to get quite aroused when
whenever I got MS back was it still in
your tongue you see yeah it's great for
oral sex